hi I'm Ryan and I'm Jerry Melissa going
tonight
we're gonna watch the trailer for
something I'm very excited about this
one is it it's gonna be anchorman 2 the
legend continues but the r-rated version
with 700 something new jokes
yeah there's it's all alternate takes
I'm excited that sounds really cool it's
never been done before to like do that
with a movie like use all alternate
takes now I love the first anchorman I'm
a huge fan of the first anchorman do you
have a soft spot and I I did like the
second one didn't love it as much as I
thought I guess you did actually no I
think about it now it's pretty [ __ ]
funny she broke my soul into like a
billion pieces she does not like the
first anchorman movie there were some
parts of it that I thought were losing
if it I admittedly gave it a chuckle or
two I really wanted my life back
anchorman took everything from me
whatever if this trailer makes her laugh
she has to watch it and she has to let
me take her legally she has to pay fines
no contract saying such things
yeah the contract when you walk out the
door sister you said it in front of
Jerry and I we've all bio-print yeah we
have two people against one you're
letting me take you to the new anchorman
movie and then afterwards we'll come
back here and it'll be covered with
flowers everywhere not rose petals
actual flowers man oh you guys see that
ankle reactive language drug use sexual
material and references yeah useful film
yeah they're releasing it okay
interesting yeah is that crazy
yeah she is really good-looking it is
distractor people are gonna be
distracted from us indonesian chick if
you're watching how you doing it seems
like a lot of dudes like i'm sure yeah
there's a couple of girls Roxie
something how you doing
whatever your damn I'm terrible with the
YouTube names
I remember the faces and the thumbnails
I don't remember
the names are my girls right around you
I know for some reason my ears feel
really all right
there for some reason have they're like
hot right now
did you get some hot ears when I'm
around a pretty girl my ears isn't light
up and I'm sweating I've never been this
nervous around a girl before like
hey we're funny look at us
I'm gonna take a notepad to theater
right now I keep Italian how many new
jobs I can find dude that movie that I
just like the idea of it the idea of it
sounds really cool just to see an
alternate version of the same movie it's
like they've had their run on the pg-13
how they can try out how it would have
done is an already yeah yeah it's true
and we get to see the glitch that's
better
it might be better it might just be
really long and redundant it might be
your favorite movie
yeah I'm gonna check that out and I'm
gonna laugh we're gonna have a good time
60% of the time I laugh
it's a [ __ ] man reference thank you
they're like I tried playing along
though Hitler mmm
anchorman 2 it was funny it was I just
like hanging out with these guys and
it's cool that most of them are famous
now except for Jeff I mean David
Koechner gets around
yeah he gets around but no one knows his
name so yeah yeah but he works you know
yeah but it always goes will ferrell
Paul Rudd Steve Carell and the guy who
plays champ yeah David Koechner yeah you
know his name but you know every actor's
name
no numbers the name do not yeah you do
name one that's my point I don't
remember any of these [ __ ] actors
names well they know what certain men
name a guy and I'll tell you who played
that guy you brought him up in the
guardians of the galaxy trailer when we
were talking about it the guy he says
Hagel Oh
Peter Serafinowicz do you know who that
is Charlotte but I like him usually
sheep in common I know we can't lose
that connection no it's like lightning
in a bottle